please welcome the talented beautiful
and inspiring adina menzel
hi hi drew can the ladies organize my
my clutter in my kitchen that's what i
need to take away from this in addition
to
meeting you i just my whole thing is
what do you do with someone like me
who's always just been a slob
well you can't do it all like you know
maybe
you need a junk drawer so you can go out
and like
do what you do that freaks out everybody
on the planet
because i think that you've been such an
amazing role model
to girls and women um
and you're such an icon how
do you like does that is that pressure
some
to be like yeah it does i
i imagine i think it's one of those
things that's like the most beautiful
gift and sometimes occurs because
i think my lucky stars every day that
i'm associated with some of these
wonderful roles and
young women that have these incredible
empowering messages
and that i get to be on a stage when
we're not in a pandemic and sing to a
sea of
young girls in blue dresses and on the
other hand
i'm a woman in her 40s um i'm a mess
my kitchen's a pigsty
i feel like a failure and it's like
you've chosen me
to to lift up your young little girls
and boys i don't know and so
um i contend with that a lot of just
feeling like a hypocrite and then
i figure if i just put it out there and
i'm authentic about it that
that at least you won't you know i don't
i
fake it till i make it that's all i can
say well
ironically as a mom i always saw
also so many girls gravitate towards
elsa and i was like oh the complicated
one
interesting and what was so great is
that the love story was between sisters
like oh my gosh i hadn't really seen
that before
and i have a younger sister three years
younger than me i actually brought her
to
the oscars my first time when i was
singing let it go at the oscars and i
brought my sister
and my sister is one of these women that
i
this month and every day of our lives um
look up to and honor and um i brought
her
from boulder colorado her and her
husband relocated for the pandemic we
rented a house nearby that has a little
pool and a little um like a pool house
that we convert to a schoolhouse and she
does a pod
because she's a fifth grade teacher and
my son is in fifth grade
so it's my son and three other kids well
as schools have been tasked to think
differently
parents have been tasked to have to do
differently and
i did home school before i started this
job for six months
and i think i lost 10 years of my life
i've never
did you overhear what they're supposed
to hand in but
it was like did you do this honey did
you do this he said get off my back mom
i want space but then i want to make
sure he's being a good student and he's
not going to miss
everything and it's just and he's and he
also did you know the kids start to
figure out that they can put these
virtual backgrounds on or
i'm not going to tell you who but one of
his friends had
took a couple shots of himself he's so
resourceful
of in different positions like this like
this whatever and then
they would he would walk away from this
screen
and then flash different shots so it
looked like he was still alive and
so she positioned it that's so ferris
bueller
genius like when he would put the
mannequin in the back
with like the snoring sounds and yeah
i've never
felt i've never felt honestly
as a self-loathing
challenged it has been the hardest
most incredible year which is why
teachers have never been more
appreciated or in the heroic forefront
no i'm totally with you and if you do
want to see a mom
in um being delirious over a pandemic
um check out this little kids show that
i went up into my son's tree house that
he never even goes in and i had to go up
there to film myself or something and
um i started singing to my camera and
reading a story and
decided i wanted to be the next mrs
rogers but um if you want to check it
out we're gonna have a second episode
coming out soon and
hopefully people will uh can can watch
with their little kids and also
have an escape and put them in front of
the ipad with something
somewhat quality and if you go to our
show website at the
drewberrymareshow.com
we'll have a feature on it and a link
right to it as well
thank you and um the i am every woman
campaign
um this is so important women's history
month
will you please tell us about this
campaign and why it's important to you
yes it's this age-old organization
called care that did the care package
that's where
that name comes from and they go around
the world
uplifting women and young girls out of
poverty
that's that's what they do and so they
teamed up with
international women's day to do this
campaign this year and then i got to go
in the studio with
one of my all-time idols i used to sing
at weddings and bar mitzvahs
before i got my big break and i would
sing through the fire you know that song
shaku khan was a hero of mine just she's
one of the greatest singers of all time
and i was in the studio
there's a big week drew and shocked a
card come on i'm doing good
that's so exciting chaka khan oh
it's incredible gosh thank you for doing
that the history of the care package
adena chaka con and women's history
month is one of the most potent
combinations i've ever heard of
adina menzel i'm so excited to make your
acquaintance
on youtube i really am thank you for
having me i'm honored to be on your show
thank you thank you so much